Mike you took over as chairman of the
memorial and museum project in 2006 a
time when people thought this project
was a disaster soaring costs the
stakeholders were fighting how'd you get
involved well somebody had to pull it
all together we had some great people
who'd made enormous progress in getting
commitments for 100 hundred and fifty
million dollars and a lot of work had
been done with the Port Authority in the
states of New York New Jersey City
federal governments but it was the
controversy had sort of taken over and
became the story itself rather than what
we were going to build and why we wanted
to build it howden as mayor I was the
logical thing to do how to cut the cost
and get everyone on the same page well
you had to make decisions as to what you
were going to build how big it was going
to be what the budget was it wasn't that
people were cooking the books it wasn't
that people were saying let's waste
money it was that everybody had a
different view of what we should build
and in that case forecasting is
virtually impossible and you don't start
out by saying you have an unlimited
budget use it and then we'll see what it
costs you just can't do that in the real
world we knew we'd have to raise an
enormous amount of money privately and
private donors wanted to know that their
money was going to be well spent and
they wanted to know that it was going to
get done but why is the New York City
Mayor was it natural for you to be the
person to take that role there was a lot
of pushback I don't remember being a lot
of pushback it really couldn't be the
governors of the state of New Jersey or
New York because they're two separate
governors and who would run it Port
Authority didn't have the expertise or
the ability to deal with the families in
any case they were the ones were going
to have to construct it and they in fact
did a very good job it was time for
somebody to deal with the families deal
with the Fourth Estate the press deal
with the insurance companies and private
owners you had to deal with the MTA who
had a railroad subway running through it
you had to deal with the Port Authority
that had path tubes running under it
there was a federal entry
Justin state interest and the artistic
community was involved and then every
religion wanted to be represented and
you need somebody to say look guys we
can't all do everything we can't include
every idea we can't in fact come up with
a plan that's going to please everybody
that's just not the real world we have a
democracy you want to listen to
everybody but then somebody's got to
make a decision and decisions are made
by executives and how is your
relationship with the family's been in
the last several years Rudy Giuliani is
the New York City Mayor synonymous with
the 911 recovery have you gotten a
tremendous amount of pushback in today
what feedback are you getting there's
there's a handful of people half a dozen
families that think everything that
we've done is wrong although I'm not
sure that they've ever proposed anything
that they thought would be better but
the vast vast vast vast bulk of
stakeholders on the family side think
that what we've done has been the right
thing to do not all of them were on
board and we made the decisions but I
think after the memorial was delivered
after they saw it after they recognized
the power in the names they all became
converts and when you have a success
it's easy to do the next one because you
have credibility originally you were
comfortable with the idea of a mosque
being built those plans have been
minimized significantly and most
recently the film that that is being
shown has the word Islamists in there
and there's been protests where do you
stand on all that well the mosque see if
you want to have the freedom to build
your religious organizations place of
worship you have to let others do it
freedom goes in both directions and from
very selfish points of view if you don't
give other people their freedoms you're
not going to have your own so building a
mosque was a no-brainer in fact it never
got built it was never enough money for
it and even in those days they were
mosque closer to Ground Zero than the
one that was proposed it just became
something that became ability to sell
newspapers and fill inches
minutes on television and radio and in
print journalism in terms of the film
itself first thing the museum has to do
is to be true to history and second
thing it has to do is to make sure that
it's accurate and doesn't ascribe
motives or interest to a billion people
that have to happen to believe in one
religion when only a handful a dozen or
two dozen people did something that was
disgraceful and tragic and despicable
it's also true that those people who
committed the terrorism on 911 did so
with some kind of a twisted view of
jihad and their religion they said so on
the tape recorders from the airplane
this is not an nobody's making this up
that's what they said and history has an
obligation to tell the truth whatever it
is not to decide what things should be
in a history book but everything has to
be in a history book we have no
credibility then what is the most
important part of the memorial that you
want exhibited my children are being
raised in New York City but they were
not alive when September 11th happened
what story do you think should be told
what's the right his story that there
were a very small handful of people who
tried to take away your children's right
to say what they want to say to believe
in what they want to believe to
associate whomever they want to
associate with to be in charge of their
own destiny and that the world came to
our aid when this cowardly act took
place and in fact democracy has come out
stronger because of this than it was
going into it and that this is a lesson
that we're going to have to keep
relearning somebody said that if you
don't remember history are doomed to
repeat it I think that's clearly true
here and we live in a world because of
much better communications and social
media
terrorists in many senses have an easier
route to go than they did before because
they can find out things and can
communicate and can get information and
so the challenges of society are greater
than they've ever been then for you as
mayor post-911 did the attack affect the
decisions you made how you govern the
city knowing that there was now a game
plan a route map for those who would
want to follow another it only changed
what we had to do in the sense that we
devoted a thousand police officers to
intelligence and counterterrorism
activities it only made a difference in
the sense that we put more police and
places for security issues where we
didn't have them before but you have to
be careful and not let that make people
afraid to go out in the streets and make
people afraid to express themselves make
people afraid to pick art that some
people don't like and they find it may
even find offensive you have to make
sure that you attract people and say
they convinced them that they have the
opportunity to be in charge of their own
destiny to build an economy you had to
make sure that we are that they are sure
that they're safe today there's double
the number of people living in lower
Manhattan than there were back then back
then there was six hotels we're about to
by the end of this year I think we'll
have 30 hotels downtown how did you get
David Koch and Jon Stewart on the same
page when it comes to this memorial
project I don't think they live on the
same planet what that's not true both
express their views David Koch George
Soros Jon Stewart Michael Bloomberg
these are people who stand up and say
what they believed when you look at
George Soros Jon Stewart David Koch and
yourself all participating in supporting
this memorial is it only a good idea
then is it individuals who also
represent the American dream well I
think though you know it's a question of
what you mean the American dream but I
think those people are all people who've
been successful
and if you go and take a look who gave
the money for the 911 memorial and
museum there's seven eight hundred
thousand different people most of them
do not have the visibility or the net
worth of these but they are just as
generous in their own ways they all
wanted to be part of this they wanted to
be able two down the road say you know I
help make that possible and they did but
people didn't want to give money because
they were afraid this was going to be an
endless project that was a black hole
well that cork that was John Whitehead
who was a great American a great New
Yorker raised 150 million dollars and
it's true that people hadn't sent in
checks yet but that was because there
was chaos and the director of the museum
Memorial who quit after that said oh
this is not going to work and left sort
of left an organization rudderless and
without hope and that's why somebody had
to step in and do it but this was a good
idea from day one and the only issue was
how big what was the design how you were
going to raise the money but not were
you gonna do this from the day I took it
over that was not an issue I I remember
the day the first thing I did is I wrote
a big check and made sure i sent the
check and then I started calling the
people who had been on that list of
making commitments first one was to
ken's north american express and I think
that day we got a check from him and
that just snow balled out there once a
few people were doing with all these
things once a few do everybody says oh
it's going to work and they get on board
and that's what leadership is all about
and Chenault and American Express was
certainly leaders and this lots of
others as well world war two memorial
took 40 years to get done would you say
this was speedy I think history will
show that given the complexity of the
construction process given the
complexity of the governmental store
process the remember this is a Port
Authority project on Port Authority land
which is owned by the state of New York
and the state of New Jersey and I think
during the ten years there are a total
of nine different governors between new
york and new jersey
each one who wanted to make sure that
they had to say and rightly so we had
questions about who owns what we had
questions about insurance what was
covered there were lawsuits there were
two functioning railroads that went
through the site that couldn't be
stopped they were dealing with the
families and making sure we were
respectful and trying to recover to the
extent humanly possible and he remains
and identify those to make sure that we
could understand going through a
recession how we also could make sure
there was economic activity down in this
area because you have to have a economy
for those left behind and I think when
you pull all that together and you're
right the book it's going to be a test
case and the conclusion will be it was
really quite amazing nothing anything as
complex as this from every point of view
has ever been done that I know of and
the short a period of time but more
importantly than the time because it
doesn't make any difference if we went
back and and it was late it's a question
of did we do the right thing in the
right way and did we do it safely not
with the exception of three firefighters
who were killed at a nearby building off
the site the Deutsche Bank building when
it was being demolished not one fatality
on the site not one in one of the most
complex tight construction projects ever
done we had enough death to be able to
do this without any more deaths number
one priority doing it right number two
all right I haven't seen it yet what is
the most special element of the museum
what took your breath to me when I saw
one of the fire engines and I wondered
what happened to the guys on that fire
engine because it just brings it back to
human beings I didn't know very many
people who died Christopher's husband
was running the Port Authority the site
at the time the World Trade Center site
one of my employee three my employees so
I didn't really know young people died
the son of a guy I worked with died you
know there's a handful of others but
that's what brings it to
this is all about people and ideas and
freedoms and it's the freedoms for those
who are left behind what I always think
we owe it to the deceased to make sure
that they're those they left behind have
a future and have what we want for
everybody in America where were you on 9
11 my campaign headquarters it was
voting day an election that was later
canceled during the day and rescheduled
three weeks later but walked with a
reporter Michael Daley from where I
voted an 80 second Street down to my
campaign headquarters on fifty-sixth
street and I was there reading a
newspaper having a cup of coffee because
there's nothing to do you had already
finished campaigning and somebody said
oh look a television on they said look
small plane hit the World Trade Center
and you could see a gash right across
the whole building I so that was not a
small plane right away did you know it
was attacker didn't of course nobody
knew his attack absolutely inconceivable
area 20 minutes later when the second
plane went in of course everybody knew
now maybe somebody said oh you know what
was a plane doing at that level but it
could have been a malfunction or who
knows what it could have been and that
the tragedy of the event I don't think
you stop to think about how why it was
what how do we get those people out of
that building and but by the second soon
as the second plane took place there was
not a surprise that there was the
Pentagon in Shanksville as well it was
obviously a concerted coordinated attack
on freedom that morning did you think at
all I don't know if I want to be mayor
of this city this seems like it's not a
big because there's more of a need than
ever before that if you're going to you
come mayor because you want to make a
difference and the more things need to
be fixed or funded or decided if it
makes the challenge all the greater and
if you're doing it for the right reasons
to try to make a difference you have a
bigger chance you may cab igg a
difference